[Music]
val don't patronize your mother she's an
amazingly intelligent woman you know i
think homosexuality a lot more ice for
you that's more i said one of the things
that's weakening this country really
you know that's what i thought until i
found out alexander the great was
talking about gays in the military how
about those dolphins huh
over the past few years lgbtq plus films
have skyrocketed and with the help of a
few classics we're taking a look at some
of the best lgbtq plus comedies to be
considered for this list a movie had to
predominantly feature gay lesbian trans
or queer characters concern itself
centrally with lgbtq plus themes present
its lgbtq plus characters in a fair and
realistic light and or be seen as a
touch point in the evolution of queer
cinema
and we recognize that some of the films
on this list will reignite healthy
debates that have been fixtures of
discussion around lgbtq plus films
straight actors playing gay characters
cis actors playing trans characters and
the historical dominance of white male
perspectives
i thought maybe we could sign up for
grindr together
you don't know what grinder is do you
it's facebook for gay people
not what it is
for now join us as we celebrate the work
of filmmakers whose talents and risks
have opened up the possibilities of
cinema as we count down the best lgbtq
plus comedies
[Music]
number 10
pride
realizing that they share common foes in
margaret thatcher the police and the
conservative press london-based gays and
lesbians lend their support to striking
coal miners in 1984 wales starring bill
nye imelda staunton dominic west and
directed by matthew warchess critics say
earnest without being didactic and
uplifting without stooping to
sentimentality pride is a joyous crowd
pleaser that genuinely works so we are
going to pick a mining town completely
at random and just ring it is that the
plan is it back the town hall the
council well it's as easy as that why
not
bypass the union altogether i think it's
inspired so do i see even bromley agrees
right here we go aha so uh what do we
want um
somewhere north industrial homicide is
that a place oh jesus christ give it to
me
if it's miners you're looking for
uh
whales of course there's a big [ __ ]
cold field that's the brecon beacons
that's a coal field yeah that is all
right what was supposed to do stick a
bloody pin in it do you know people
getting no i haven't been back there in
16 years why not
well let's just say there isn't always a
welcome in the hillsides
shall i get you the phone book
well
what's the worst that can happen oh
hello i represent a bunch of screaming
homosexuals may i inquire about communal
what's that gonna give us
nothing i'd just like to inquire
number nine the kids are all right
jules and nick have been together for
almost 20 years and have two teenage
offspring named joni and lazer who were
conceived via artificial insemination
unbeknown to their mothers joni and
laser seek out their biological father a
restaurateur named paul complications
arise when the teens bond with paul and
invite him into their lives starring
julianne moore annette benning mark
ruffalo and directed by lisa chalidenko
critics say worthwhile is both a
well-acted ensemble piece and as a smart
warm statement on family values the kids
are all right is remarkable
no i was asking because i remember when
i was reading your file back when we
were looking for
uh
you know um
sperm
potential sure anyway um you said that
you were studying international
relations
oh yeah wow that was a uh
that was a long time ago
um
yeah i was considering it
but then i dropped out of school
oh
you dropped out of college yeah it just
wasn't my thing
no huh why is that i don't know it just
seemed like a
a massive waste of money after a while
you know i was just sitting on my asses
and the people spout ideas i could just
as easily have learned in a book
oh
okay
i'm not i'm not saying that uh you know
i think that that higher learning
uniformly blows oh you know i think
college is great for some people joanie
i'm sure you're gonna love it but just
i'm a doer that's all i learned it's
just me i'm weird that way i guess
number eight love simon
everyone deserves a great love story but
for 17 year old simon spear it's a
little more complicated he hasn't told
his family or friends that he's gay and
he doesn't know the identity of the
anonymous classmate that he's fallen for
online resolving both issues proves
hilarious terrifying and life-changing
starring nick robinson josh dumel
jennifer garner and directed by greg
berlanti critics say love simon hits its
coming-of-age beats more deftly than
many entries in this well-traveled genre
and represents an overdue if not
entirely successful milestone of
inclusion
hey guys
hey hey
come talk to us
how was the party it was really fun was
it yeah
aces
uh well
thanks for letting me stay over yeah
yeah you've been staying over 10 years
it's um
you don't have to thank us oh
yeah thanks
john lennon who's wearing the woman's
sweater
and he's drunk
definitely so how do we feel about it
well he he didn't drive drunk and he's
home before curfew so
good
that's what i thought we thought yeah
that's what we think right yeah we're
good parents
number seven appropriate behavior
a secretly bisexual brooklynite from a
traditional persian family struggles
with her identity and the disintegration
of her relationship with her girlfriend
starring rebecca henderson scott adset
holly pfeiffer and desiree akavon who
also directed the film critics say warm
funny and quietly profound appropriate
behavior serves as a thoroughly
compelling calling card for writer
director and star desiree akavon i
actually need to stock up on panties my
ex-girlfriend uh cut up most of mine so
i'm gonna need more what about bras i
don't wear those
why not i just don't have that much to
work with so it feels a little silly
you know like when little girls carry
purses
what's your name
shereen shireen
you are a woman and you have breasts and
there's nothing wrong with them
yeah i know
you deserve a sexy supportive bra just
like any other woman
okay
you were with a woman for how long and
she didn't help you find the right bra
a while
it sounds like your ex what's her name
maxine
sounds like maxine was destructive to
your panties and your self-esteem i'm so
sorry is this really necessary
i'm fine i just need underwear just
because your breasts are small doesn't
mean they're not legitimate
i know
it's okay to be angry oh my god let's
try that on
you know it's like i didn't think i
deserved a bra because i don't see
myself as a real woman
number six book smart
academic overachievers amy and molly
thought keeping their noses to the
grindstone gave them a leg up on their
high school peers but on the eve of
graduation the best friends suddenly
realized that they may have missed out
on the special moments of their teenage
years determined to make up for lost
time the girls decide to cram four years
of not to be missed fun into one night a
chaotic adventure that no amount of book
smarts could prepare them for starring
caitlyn deaver beanie feldstein jessica
williams and directed by olivia wilde
critics say fast-paced funny and fresh
book smart does this seemingly
impossible by adding a smart new spin to
the coming of age comedy amy and i are
gonna skype the puzzle every single week
so we will send you our sunday times
yeah you know what why don't i just give
you to my number that way you guys can
call or text me if you need anything
yeah yeah
just make our lives that's true
definitely i'll give you mine after no
no i'll just share the content i can
just i'm just gonna share the content
wait wait it's fine i thought there are
no cell phones allowed in class or are
there exceptions for us kissers hey
a dollar in the swear jar i'm so sorry
these shorts they don't have pockets
okay excuse me excuse me jesus christ oh
my god
no spatial awareness of this
baby
yeah did you just score your teacher's
phone number
yeah
nice
hey miss fine you should come party with
us tonight did you just ask miss fine if
she wants to party with you you think
she wants to watch you and your friends
get drunk and break things yeah i'm
sorry hold on i was having a
conversation with her you're not part of
this sit down theo
number five tangerine
after hearing that her boyfriend pimp
cheated on her while she was in jail a
sex worker and her best friend set out
to find him and teach him and his new
lover a lesson starring katana kiki
rodriguez maya taylor karen kerrigullian
and directed by sean baker critics say
tangerine shatters casting conventions
and its filmmaking techniques are up to
the minute but it's an old-fashioned
comedy at heart and a pretty wonderful
one at that i had two dollars
two dollars
you know what i spent that on
what the bus and the donut
since him
since yes now
it don't matter we're here now sit down
you at least give me a christmas present
well i mean like
like yeah like i get our gift is like me
[ __ ] running [ __ ] like saving money
like make because i know you was getting
out today i was what i was gonna do
surprise you was gonna take you to
roscoe's tomorrow for maybe like
like a nice christmas dinner [ __ ] like i
thought that'd be special
what
number four shiva baby
while at a jewish funeral service with
her parents a college student has an
awkward encounter with her sugar daddy
and her ex-girlfriend starring rachel
senate molly gordon polly draper and
directed by emma seligman critics say a
ruefully funny calling card for debuting
director emma seligman shiva baby
transcends its sitcom setup with strong
performances and satisfying insights
who died abby
uncle bourne's second wife's sister you
remember her no i don't think so hmm she
used to play bridge with bobby really
yeah
oh mom i can't eat that why not i'm
vegetarian you're killing me i've told
you it's so many times you have not
eaten a single thing all day that's
because we just got here you look like
gwyneth paltrow on food stamps oh my god
and not in a good way you know what anne
haas says she says she thinks your
animals
danielle
are you listening to me hey hey
oh my god
that's paul and cheryl shapiro's nephew
you're so cute
you know what
he has a cousin that works in publishing
maybe he can help you mom stop i don't i
have to go to the bathroom
number three the half of it
a shy introverted student helps the
school jock woo a girl whom secretly
they both want starring leah lewis
daniel diemer alexis lemire and directed
by alice wu critics say for viewers in
search of an uncommonly smart tender and
funny coming-of-age story the half of it
has everything
hold up
what is wrong with you i'm sorry i uh
ten dollars for three pages twenty
dollars for three to ten not in the over
ten page biz no i'm not trying to cheat
nobody is which class is it for
no it's not oh
what's this a letter you write letters
these days i i thought i'd seen romantic
can't help you no i just need a few
words good ones i'm not writing to ask
her for
to some girl
it'd be wrong a letter is personal it's
supposed to be authentic that'd be
awesome no i can't be you being authent
get a thesaurus you spell check good
luck romeo
number two my beautiful laundrette
in a seedy corner of london omar is
given a rundown laundromat by his uncle
who hopes to turn it into a successful
business soon after omar is attacked by
a group of racist punks but defuses the
situation when he realizes that their
leader is his former lover johnny the
men resumed their relationship and
rehabilitate the laundromat together but
various social forces threatened to
compromise their success starring daniel
day-lewis gordon warnack syed jaffrey
and directed by stephen frears critics
say my beautiful laundrette is fast and
all over the place because it has so
much to say in show including a highly
watchable fresh-faced daniel day lewis
you know
i thought
i'd come to the wrong place
that i'd suddenly found myself in a
ladies hairdressing cellar on finner
where one might get a pink rinse
do you do a good pink rinse johnny
or are you still a fascist
you used to give us a lot of good advice
sir
when i was little now when you were
little
what's it made of you
are you a politician
journalist
trade unionist
no
you're an underpants cleaner
oh dear
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
hedwig and the angry inch
a german emigrant living in a trailer in
kansas is the victim of a botched sex
change operation adapted from the
critically acclaimed off-broadway rock
theater head hedwig and the angry inch
tells the story of the internationally
ignored rock singer hedwig and her
search for stardom and love starring
michael pitt miriam shore steven trask
and john cameron mitchell who also
directed the film critics say hedwig and
the angry inch may very well be the next
rocky horror midnight movie it not only
knows how to rock but hedwig's story has
an emotional poignancy it is clear that
i must find my other half but is it he
or she and two people actually become
one
[Applause]
i never knew that woman before that
night and i never knew she wasn't a
woman i've got a sweet two
monster trucks in wichita when it comes
to huge openings a lot of people think
of me
okay everybody
[Music]
rock stars
[Music]
hey boy take a walk on the white side
the bird cage
in this remake of the classic french
farce lacajo fall engaged couple val
goldman and barbara keeley shakily
introduce their future in-laws val's
father armond is a gay miami drag club
owner he pretends to be straight and
attempts to hide his relationship with
albert his life partner and the club's
flamboyant star attraction and barbara's
father is a controversial republican
senator starring robin williams nathan
lane gene hackman and directed by mike
nichols critics say mike nichols
wrangles agreeably amusing performances
from robin williams and nathan lane in
this fun if not quite essential remake
of the french comedy la cajo falls
are you trying to ruin me don't look at
me
i'm hideous hidey is fat and hideous
agador i'm in such pain i know honey
it's gonna pass oh no it'll never pass i
hate my life
there is a packed house okay that's all
i am to you isn't it a meal ticket
never mind about my feelings never mind
about my suffering it's just about your
show
not even our show your show well
i want a palimony agreement and i want
one now well i don't have a palamoni
agreement on me right now is tomorrow
right don't use that tone to me what
tone that sarcastic contemptuous tone
that means you know everything because
you're a man and i know nothing because
i'm a woman you're not a woman oh you
bastard and before we get to number one
here is another honorable mention
the rocky horror picture show
in this cult classic sweethearts brad
and janet stuck with a flat tire during
a storm discovered the eerie mansion of
dr frankenferder a trans scientist as
their innocence is lost brad and janet
meet a houseful of wild characters
including a rocking biker and a creepy
butler through elaborate dances and rock
songs frankenfurter unveils his latest
creation a muscular man named rocky
starring tim curry susan sarandon barry
botzwick and directed by jim sharman
critics say rocky horror picture show
brings its quirky characters in tight
but it's narrative thrust that really
drives audiences insane and keeps them
doing the time warp again a sinister
servant named riff ref i remember
doing the time war
and brad and janet my name is brad mages
just a couple of clean-cut kids this is
my fiance jared weiss
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr scott
[Music]
so give yourself over to absolute
pleasure
and finally number one all about my
mother
a greek saying states that only women
who have washed their eyes with tears
can see clearly this saying does not
hold true for manuela the night a car
ran over her son esteban manuela cried
until her eyes ran completely dry far
from seeing clearly the present and the
future become mixed up in darkness she
begins looking for esteban's father who
is now a trans woman starring cecilia
roth eloy azerine marissa paredes and
directed by pedro almodovar critics say
almo weaves together a magnificent
tapestry of femininity with an
affectionate wink to classics of theater
and cinema in this poignant story of
love loss and compassion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you